en los últimos días funerales en Israel
por la muerte violenta de siete personas
en una sinagoga de Jerusalén este y
también en los territorios palestinos
después de un operativo israelí en
jenning que acabó con la vida De 10
personas Israel y las autoridades
palestinas han visto una escalada en sus
relaciones incluyendo la ruptura en
cooperación en materia de seguridad en
ese contexto llega el secretario de
estado de Estados Unidos Anthony blinken
a la región queremos que las partes no
cesen la cooperación en materia de
seguridad sino que realmente mejoren la
coordinación en materia de seguridad
instamos a la desescalada y a la calma
de la situación
la administración vaivén llegó al poder
con el objetivo de dejar atrás 20 años
de protagonismo internacional de medio
oriente para enfocarse en Rusia y China
sin embargo ante los últimos
acontecimientos buscan evitar que la
situación entre Israel y las autoridades
palestinas se salga de control es la
visita de más alto nivel desde que
Benjamín netanyahu retomó el poder hace
EEUU quiere mantener a Israel como su
mayor Aliado en el mundo Pero existe
preocupación en Washington por el
gobierno israelí más a la ultraderecha
de la historia entre los temas a tratar
la voluntad de miembros del gobierno de
anexionartis Jordania y una polémica
reforma judicial con netanyahu envuelto
en varios escándalos de corrupción un
equilibrio difícil ya que Estados Unidos
también quiere salvar la estabilidad con
las autoridades palestinas reivindicando
nuevamente la solución de dos estados
algo que parece difícil del mismo modo
que sucede con su otra apuesta para la
región de revivir el acuerdo nuclear de
2015 con Irán por lo que el viaje de
blingen tendrá como objetivo mantener la
situación bajo control